on s'est dit que le marathon c'est une
course qui est très importante au québec
après vingt mille coureurs si le
marathon peut devenir un chef de file ou
un peu un modèle pour les autres
puis vous savez notre ville la ville de
montréal a aussi d intérêt à ce que ces
événements deviennent de plus vert
possible non pourquoi le marathon
prendrait pas une décision qui doit
prendre alors nous là on a l'intention
de se faire examiner
pour prendre les meilleures décisions en
développement durable dont on a un
extrait d'entrevue du directeur de
course du marathon de montréal qui
faisait cette prise de conscience qu'il
faut que le marathon international de
montréal fasse un virage vert et
d'ailleurs l'événement s'est associé à
deux organisations donc équiterre et le
conseil québécois des événements
écoresponsables on reçoit ce matin quand
une tower qui est directeur général
d'équiterre bonjour madame taux
allemands matin on parle d'un virage
vert pour le marathon de montréal mais
un virage à venir là vous êtes sur le
terrain toute la fin de semaine pour
voir comment ça se passe au marathon
c'est exact on est très heureux que le
marathon nous a approchés ça fait
plusieurs années qu'on réfléchisse à
cette question là des événements
sportifs et qui ont responsable et c'est
ça le marathon s'est dit que l'année
prochaine ils vont mettre en place des
mesures plus vigoureuses pour faire
vraiment un virage et que ça soit
significatif alors il est déjà certaine
mesure qu'ils ont mises en place mais on
est encore on a du chemin à faire disons
pour que ça soit un événement modèle oui
parce que quand on regarde un événement
comme celui là avec des milliers de
personnes qui courent inévitablement ça
veut dire des milliers
deux bouteilles de plastique qui sont
remises comme ça pendant la course
ça c'est justement une un aspect auquel
vous voulez vous attaquer mais cette
année je pense que le marathon ne
distribuera plus de bouteille oui il ya
eu des efforts qui ont été faits de ce
côté là mais c'est clair que lors d'un
événement à sportif est souvent un
événement général qu'ont produit
beaucoup de matières résiduelles ont 10
5 fois plus qu'à la normale alors on est
à l'extérieur on accepte des objets on
prend de l'eau on va avoir des produits
emballés
donc on va produire des matières
résiduelles qui sont souvent pour
recycler parce qu'il ya toujours des
installations pour capter ça donc l'idée
c'est vraiment de mettre en place une
série de mesures pour éviter cette prose
empreinte environnementale quand vous
l'avez dit quand c'est des milliers de
personnes sans impacter la wii est ce
que vous le fait déjà dans d'autres
événements d'aller voir et de réduire
l'empreinte écran commencé à se pencher
sur la question il ya plusieurs années
d'abord sur les produits promotionnels
qu'on distribue mais ensuite on a décidé
de faire un événement nous mêmes donc on
a une course éco-responsable 100% pur
produit depuis quatre ans donc on
connaît les difficultés que ça peut
représenter pour l'organisation c'est
clair que c'est différent quand c'est à
grande échelle comme pour un marathon
c'est beaucoup plus de personnes
notre course est tout petit mais je vous
dirais que depuis qu'on fait ça et avec
d'autres groupes qui vont accompagner à
les promoteurs de course
le phénomène se répand non seulement
pour les courses mais également pour les
événements tout court ce sont des défis
quand même de taille
qu'on regarde sol à tout ce qui est à
faire dans un événement déjà il ya les
déplacements alors si d'emblée on
sensibilise en donnant des des tickets
de transport en commun ce qui se fait
cette année à au marathon de montréal
déjà on va éviter pour les transports si
on donne des billets de transport en
commun à tous les coureurs à tous ceux
qui se sont inscrits au marathon cette
année tout à fait et on ne donne pas de
bouteilles d'eau de plastique ce sont
des mesures quand même assez important
oui ce sont des mesures significatives
on croit que ya encore beaucoup de
chemin à faire
on peut penser à tous les emballages des
produits qu'on va distribuer pour manger
on peut même penser aux produits
promotionnels
alors c'est souvent la norme dans ces
événements là qu'on va distribuer un tee
shirt en souvenir mais les gens qui
couvre les marathons ayant beaucoup de
t-shirts pis si on se promène dans les
friperies on voit qu'il ya beaucoup de
ce t-shirt les marathons et puis c'est
ça y est c'est une production non
nécessaire faut se rappeler que les gens
il court pour être en santé la santé de
la planète ça va de pair avec la santé
environnementale
donc l'idée c'est d'avoir du plaisir en
courant et de faire attention à son
empreinte
est ce qu'on peut penser que c'est
réalisable l'objectif zéro déchet pour
l'année prochaine pour le marathon de
mon frère pour l'année prochaine
je pense qu'on pourrait être près du
zéro déchet 100% zéro déchet c'est
peut-être difficile mais près du zéro
déchet avec la crise crée climatiques
qui s'annoncent il ya des milliers de
l'étudiant qui vont manifester dans les
rues la semaine prochaine pour dire
qu'il faut pas attendre et le virage il
doit être majeur donc la théorie des
petits pas ne s'applique plus il faut
vraiment visé
réduire ses impacts on peut s'approcher
très certainement du zéro déchet donc
vous allez être sur le terrain toute la
fête semaine au marathon de montréal
l'entente merci beaucoup merci merci à
vous au revoir